every day I speak to my beautiful and
Brilliant cousin Ora who lives in
Israel in normal times we talk about
which cousin is the bigger
idiot which honey cake recipe to
use which books we're reading the family
stories from bellarus this is not Ora
these are other people in bellarus the
conversations are a beacon for me and
they fill my soul and enter my
books the other day Ora brought up a a
Romanian philosopher named Emil
Soren he was a
miserable Insomniac who drove everyone
nuts because of
this that's actually my favorite book of
his but the better title the the more
accurate translation is on the
inconvenience of being
born so he
was relentless in talking about how
horrible it was to be alive and he did
this until the age of 85 when he died
which is incredibly
ironic but I must give him credit he
does bring up the essential dilemma why
are we here for what purpose but today I
don't really want to dwell on the morose
let's talk about other
things that's not the right
slide that's the right
slide so here's
PR dead obviously or you think he's
sleeping but he's dead from a series of
paintings that I've done called dead in
bed which includes Tolstoy and check off
of course in normal times and these are
not normal times these are Grim times
when the world is is a wash in war and
killing but in normal times I have a
routine in the early morning hours with
a strong cup of coffee I read the
obituaries the infusion of coffee and
biography affords me a way to reflect
and it might seem too soon in the day to
start with such a tremendous topic but
it is a jol to action because it reminds
me how fragile and how vulnerable we all
are and how quickly Our Lives can end
the night is
different then I watch an endless stream
of murder
mysteries preferably British watching
them is the kind of Solace I call this
the murder and minip portion of the
day we have a problem we solve the
problem people seem briefly obset by the
murders so many in every episode but
there is no time to brood because they
have to film the next episode and they
all seem to say get on with it and the
idea of prevailing over
evil is my lullabi and I sleep but what
of the day that lies ahead every one of
us invents the day every single day is
invented the actual first day was 13.8
billion years ago more or less and maybe
with the information from the web
telescope we can actually see the
beginning of time which is an
incomprehensible idea of of course but
what does that perspective afford US
when contemplating which tutu to wear or
which insult to respond to or what book
to
write sometimes the day is too long
excruciatingly long and I get out of bed
I look longingly at the bed and I say to
the bed I will be back
soon and in between there are things to
know and things to not know here is a
map of the United
States made from memory by my mother
Sarah uh Sarah was the dean of American
History at
Harvard actually
not her family fled the pgrs of bellarus
for Palestine in the 1930s and in 1954
our family moved to New York City her
acute sense of the Absurd permeated
everything in our life in the best way
possible this map for me is the gold
standard of knowledge knowledge as
imagination knowledge as humor knowledge
as not giving a damn what the correct
answer is to anything
[Applause]
ever
Sarah this is Sarah did not speak that
much she really she was a few words and
we really listened to her and what are
the obvious assets of not speaking so
many no worries about repeating yourself
or boring others or boring yourself or
being misunderstood no regrets of having
set something inconsiderate or too
considerate or too vanel or too
provocative or just just plain stupid
and altogether
insufferable that is what happens when
we speak it is inevitable no
justification at all for saying much of
what we say and if we examine this
notion to its ultimate
conclusion obviously the answer is no
more dinner
parties wait you say none at all what if
the tollo invite me who are pictured
here sure but have you hung out with the
tollo or what if Anthony and Cleopatra
invite me should I attend okay I say but
at your own Peril you know what happened
to
them on the other hand if you are
invited and let's just say it's really
lovely to be invited you never know what
you're going to see that will be a
painting or hear that might be a story
some fragment some gesture an image of a
dog sitting on a green chair in front of
radishes and flowers and let's not
forget connectedness Congeniality
conviviality
camaraderie bonomi Mart laughter what is
wrong with that nothing absolutely
nothing I used to be ashamed of my
inconsistencies now I Revel in them
everything is in Conflict everything has
an opposite you are not bound to be one
thing a truly liberating notion for me
you might tell the truth or you might
lie you might be kind or
unkind selfish or generous quick or
thick and in the midst of that confusion
and that tumult the work
blossoms to have meaningful work is a
Salvation and one of my greatest
Pleasures is just there thing and my
children always say that I get too close
to people when strangers on the street
and just stare at them at their features
because I'm so entranced so I have to be
pulled away a little little bit but but
then I can go into my studio and report
on what I have encountered and then as a
bonus the Bliss of mixing colors of
being alone and listening to music and
going into another world here is a
painting from a visit that I did to
seisan Studio the walls are painted gray
this is the recipe for any of those who
need it black white ochre and aquamarine
now as a Talisman every painting I do
includes seisan Gray
writing of course is
different finding the idea plucking a
word out of the air but which word and
then a sentence but which sentence and
then a paragraph and which paragraph and
it never stops so many words I could not
live without both painting and writing
and one supports the other in obvious
ways in both the struggle is invisible
but palpable I say the tears are
invisible but they're definitely there
how do I deal with never good enough
easy
self-loathing is a truly ugly expression
but it is an unavoidable condition the
crushing anxiety of not getting it right
of not finding the truth of feeling
worthless if you look at it one way it
could be helpful to have doubt and
dismay plowing through the muck of
Despair leads to a sense of humanism and
perseverance on the other
hand
how absurd and tedious to be in the
grips of
self-doubt what a waste of time that
Insidious insecurity what of finding
your work and your place on Earth what
of self-confidence what of the Bliss of
finding the right color or the right
word what of sheer Joy what is wrong
with that nothing absolutely nothing
after reading the obituaries I go for a
walk which is a Salvation here is Robert
waler who wrote one of my favorite books
called walk which I highly suggest you
read walking and not thinking is the
favorite state an empty brain which I
call my best brain is the only way to
have any ideas to allow surprises to
appear Sol tour ambulando they thought
of this before I did long ago walking
solves all problems without trying
walking leads to the pleasure of sitting
perhaps on a bus going down Fifth Avenue
and looking at the entire world around
you with a great sense of well-being
one day at a farmer's market I saw a
woman carrying an absolutely gigantic
cabbage when I asked to photograph her
she looked really
annoyed and for some reason I was so
delighted by her crankiness it seemed so
authentic and true let's just say what
we feel uh it made me think of all the
things women hold literally and
metaphorically balloons and
grudges and heavy loads and
cabbages and stupendous love and
courage and a pink ukulele Under a
Cherry Tree and from this a book was
formed women holding things what do
women
hold the home and the family and the
children and the food the friendships
the work the work of the world and the
work of Being Human the memories and the
troubles and the the sorrows and the
triumphs and the love men do as well but
not quite in the same
way sometimes when I'm feeling
particularly happy or content I think I
can provide sustenance for Legions of
human beings I can hold the entire world
in my arms other times I can barely
cross the room and I drop my arms Frozen
there is never an end to holding and
certainly there is often the feeling of
never doing enough and then there is the
next day and the next day and one holds
on I
dreamt someone else was stupid for a
change such a
relief albe it a fleeting
one a few years ago I did an illustrated
edition of The Autobiography of Alice B
toas written by the inimitable gertrud
Stein Alice and gertude lived a singular
life one of intense creativity and
equally intense Domesticity and one
could not exist without the other that
to me is the ideal of Life family and
work my son Alex and I made a short film
called my name is Alice be toas and for
a brief day I became Alice with two
extra noses on my nose here is a short
clip from the end of the
film
[Music]
it took Picasso 90 sittings to paint
geruth Stein's portrait nobody thought
it looked like her but he said don't
worry it
will but actually I don't know if he
knew anything about what he was talking
about oh you know Picasso he was
[Music]
impossible
thank you very
much oh this looks
delicious absolutely
[Music]
delicious
the hot dog was delicious and dancing
down Fifth Avenue was a complete joy and
as we say in our family doing almost
everything in the strangeness of life
through the Sorrows of life live thank
you very
much